[Music]
hey you guys
doing another book review and i'm going
to tell you right from the outset
i'll get into this in a bit because
there are a lot of really seems like a
lot of strangely divisive
reviews of this it seems to be a real
love it or
hate it kind of book which i don't
really get like
now that i've read it but whatever uh
but yeah so this would be
the 2012 novel pen pal
by dathan auerbach i [ __ ] loved this
and once i did some research into how
this book came about
it actually made me love it even more
because i think what ended up happening
with me this came out like i said a long
time ago like
well not a long time ago but you know
i'm old so but uh yeah so 2012
was kind of a long time ago and i guess
i missed out on the big hype train
about this book back then and i only
ended up hearing about it later on
because i saw that it was uh recommended
you know on a lot of different channels
and i think bloody disgusting had even
uh singled it out as one of their 10
best novels that for that year
and it sounded like really cool but like
i said i went into it
just basically knowing the title and the
just barest barest kind of minimum
plot synopsis of what it was going to be
about and that's kind of how i like to
go into stuff
so i will say i'm going to discuss
things that happen in this book i don't
think i'm not going to spoil it outright
or anything because i really would
recommend that you read it
but i kind of wanted to talk a lot more
i don't know this is just one of those
books like i said that it's better not
knowing anything because i literally did
not know anything about this book i
didn't know about its history
like how it kind of came to into being
and i think that's kind of the best way
to approach it because i never knew like
what direction it was going
so i will say that and like i said for
whatever reason i was scrolling through
a lot of the
i don't know like on amazon it seems to
have
almost 100 five star ratings which like
i said i probably would give this five
stars to because i just
i don't know i got like really immersed
in that i got like really i got like
really really into this book and i'm
still like thinking about it even though
i finished it a couple days ago
but when i went over to goodreads it
seemed like it was a lot more
divided like there was a lot of four and
five star reviews people said like oh
this is one of the best books ever
it was so creepy and all this other
stuff but then there seemed to be a lot
a weirdly large amount of reviews that
were like one and two stars
being like oh it was kind of a cool idea
but it was really poorly written
it was this it was that like the dude
rambled too much it was non-linear blah
blah
it's like and i don't know i didn't
really get a lot of the criticisms yes
it's non-linear and i know some people
don't like that but i never got the
impression i didn't get the impression
it was poorly written or that it needed
to be edited or anything like that i was
just so immersed in the story
that nothing really stood out to me as
being
bad or that the writer was inexperienced
or anything like that so that was like
really surprising for me
reading that but you know whatever
that's neither here nor there so the
story behind this and i've read a couple
of interviews with the author
it's kind of awesome and also kind of
like inspirational
so basically the author uh under the
handle
a thousand vultures he was a fan
of the no sleep subreddit which i think
most people know what it is but if you
don't know what it is
uh it's obviously a subreddit you know
uh you know
a smaller forum that people post
essentially creepypasta stories but the
thing about no sleep is that you're
supposed to post them
as if they're true stories even if
obviously
uh supernatural things or whatever
happened in them and everyone is sort of
just
operating under the thing that
everything on there is true they're
giving you the benefit of that doubt
just to make the story scarier so
they're essentially like uh you know
campfire stories so
dathan auerbach was a big fan of reading
no sleep and he thought to himself even
though he'd never really written any
fiction before
he's like oh maybe i should write one
and see what happens
so he wrote a story called footsteps a
short story
and it was fictional but he wrote it as
though it was real as you're supposed to
do on no sleep
and it was based on something that had
actually happened to him in his life or
a memory that he had from childhood
even though he said the memory i had was
of waking up on my front porch
being really cold and just laying there
in my underwear and not not remembering
how i got there
and him saying that my mom says that
that never happened but he's like i
i still remember it so he kind of used
that as a jumping off point for the
story like which like i said was called
footsteps
he posted it he said he wrote it in one
day and he posted it
and it got such a positive response and
so many people
asking him about well what happened then
and you know what is you know what else
is going on behind all of this
that he started adding to it you know
doing other stories like other memories
from his childhood
that all kind of linked together a
little bit so i think there ended up
being like six stories
and it got a lot of buzz i mean they
even did um
you know there's that no sleep podcast
and they did an audio version of it
and finally people said well you know
what why don't you like adapt it once
you put it all into a book like make a
novel out of it and he's like well i
don't really know how to go about that
because like i said he'd never really
written any fiction before
and he was kind of surprised at the
positive you know uh feedback that he
was getting for these stories that he
had written like quite quickly
and hadn't really intended for them to
be a longer narrative
so they were just kind of like a series
of i would call it like a series of
connected
vignettes sort of and the novel is kind
of like that too but i think that it
works in its favor
uh rather than against it and i might
get into a little bit why that is later
on
so he decided he was going to
self-publish it uh so he started his own
imprint which he called a thousand
vultures which like i said was his
original uh reddit handle
and he decided to do a kickstarter uh to
help out with the publishing costs you
know cover design and uh that and
editing and that kind of thing
so he uh initially put the kickstarter
at fifteen hundred dollars because that
would cover
you know buying the isbn numbers and all
of that uh nonsense
and he ended up getting almost sixteen
thousand dollars
uh instead just because so many people
were really into this story and really
wanted to read it so like i said
immediately and immediately after it was
published he got like all kind of like
movie deals i don't think any of them
uh have come to fruition at least as of
this writing although i think this would
make an
excellent excellent uh independent like
a low-budget independent movie i think
that would be really really good
if it was done right i think he was
actually even floored as to
him just knocking out a story in a day
that was sort of like a
you know based on something that
happened in his childhood and it was
like kind of creepy
and then it just really took off and
that it ended up being this whole novel
so like i said back in 2012 there was a
massive
uh you know hype about this when the
novel was first
coming out i wasn't privy to that
because like i said i'd kind of uh
i was kind of more into reading
nonfiction at that time and i was
missing out on a lot of
uh horror fiction it was coming out
sadly but uh i finally got around to
reading this book and like i said i
thought
this was fantastic
now as i said it's not structured
exactly
like a traditional novel but that said
it's not that strange
either if you like creepypasta if you
and if you like like the no
sleep subreddit and you like those kind
of stories on there and how it's told
and this just kind of
like it's someone telling you a story or
like a memory that they had
then you will probably really dig this
because that's the tone of it so
we start out with uh the narrator who is
never named
it's funny because i saw a couple other
like booktubers reviewing this and they
were just kind of like oh they thought
it was really weird
that you never found out what the
narrator's name was and i said you know
what
i was like so into the story that i
never noticed until like afterward when
i was thinking about it because i
i thought that he had a name but then i
guess not the more i thought about i was
like oh yeah i guess they never did say
what his name was but it didn't
matter i don't know and in a way like
them not
naming him or or her i guess it could
have been a girl as well although i got
the impression that it was a boy and
never really saying
where it took place or when it took
place other than it being a suburb
kind of a vaguely maybe 80s or 90s time
period
somewhere around there probably
somewhere in the south because i think
he just made one offhand comment
comment about you know it not it never
getting cold enough to snow where he was
so i assumed that it was probably
florida and indeed when i looked up the
author later on he's from pensacola
which is a florida panhandle
so i assume that he was just talking
about florida but it doesn't matter
because i think the thing about keeping
the narrator nameless
uh the place and time that it's taking
place
vague i think it does it goes a long way
toward
universalizing the story because this is
a story where
you can really project yourself into
this kid's childhood
and even if nothing this horrible
happened to you when you were a kid
you can still relate to a lot of the
feelings that the protagonist had and a
lot of the
adventures that he would go on with his
friend and all this other kind of stuff
so as i said this book is a series of
several interconnected vignettes they
are not linear
most of them take place right around the
time that the narrator was
uh in kindergarten or first grade and
then a couple of them take place later
on like when he was 14 or 15 years
old and it's kind of told from the point
of view of someone
now who is looking back and
reconstructing
these significant times in his childhood
and piecing everything together
so you do actually find out what the
larger story is
but i think the greatest thing about
this and the greatest thing about it
being in a non-linear way and being
presented the way it's presented
is that to me it seemed very much to
mimic
the way that you think about your
childhood like you can't remember it
exactly
you know some things happened back then
that didn't have any significance to you
because you didn't understand them
because you were a kid
but then later on when you start
thinking about it you're like holy crap
like it must have been this that the
other thing
so it really had that kind of um that
kind of aspect to it which i really
really liked
so a lot of the you know a lot of the
vignettes
they kind of overlap a little bit and
like i said they jump around in time a
little bit so some of them like
you know the first memory that's told
isn't necessarily the first one that
happened because sometimes he'll go back
and
talk about something that happened
before that um some people found that
confusing i did not like i said it's not
really that big a deal and i think it's
kind of cool because
it's almost kind of like he's going back
and remembering
one thing and that spurs the memory of
something else that maybe happened at a
totally different time so it's all like
interrelated
and it's each one is like a little piece
of the puzzle and then by the end
you pretty much know what the whole
puzzle is
but i really really liked that aspect of
you know your childhood memories and
them not seeming
scary necessarily or significant to you
at the time or there was a lot of stuff
that you didn't know
because one of the things about this
story is that all of a lot of the
horrific [ __ ] that was going on
he was just like six years old or
whatever so his mom kept a lot of stuff
from him so some of the things that
happened like were kind of creepy from
his point of view like as a six year old
but his mom had a lot more information
than he was privy to
so in hindsight it's very scary it was
very scary for him but at the time he
didn't
exactly know what was going on so it's
that kind of thing too so i thought that
was really like brilliantly done
so basically the kind of outline of the
plot of this so the unnamed narrator
he's talking about there's kind of like
a short thing at the beginning where
he's talking about like the nature of
memory and stuff which i thought was
really good and like a really insightful
uh
kind of breakdown of how people's
memories work and things like that like
when you're remembering
things that happen in your childhood
which is kind of uh related to what i
was just talking about and then he goes
into this thing where um the first
part of the story which is just called
footsteps like i said that was kind of
the
first uh story that he had posted and
basically you have your narrator and he
is remembering this one time
that he woke up in the middle of the
night
in the woods behind his house where he
used to play and he couldn't figure
out how he got there because his feet
were not dirty so
either it was like some supernatural
[ __ ] or
you know someone carried him there and
then left him in the middle of the woods
for whatever reason
so this story is just kind of like it's
good because you don't really know
if it's gonna go in a supernatural
direction is it not you know what i mean
so
so it's really good because it's really
ambiguous
you know he just wakes up in the middle
of the night he can't figure out who got
there like at first i thought like oh
maybe it was a nightmare but it's like
it does actually happen because he
eventually finds his way back home his
mom is called the police and like all
this other kind of stuff is going on
so after that vignette which as i said
doesn't it at first it's almost just
kind of like this nightmarish sort of
inter
introduction and him telling about
something that's scary that happened to
him when he was a kid
but the significance of it really
doesn't come into play
until later on and i think it's the so
the way it's constructed is like really
cool because
even though it jumps around in time a
little bit every vignette
casts light on stuff that's happened
before so you really have to kind of
read the whole thing through
and this is one that i think really
probably would need to be read
a second and maybe a third time to like
catch all of the
connections and everything like that
between everything that's going on
because i don't
necessarily think i caught everything
but because there's a lot of
uh interrelated things going on in this
book so then the second part
and uh you know where the name pen pal
came from
the second vignette is called balloons
and the narrator is talking about when
he was in kindergarten
and he um he and his best friend josh
who he describes how he met josh like in
a vignette like later on
but at this point they know each other
and there's a project in their
kindergarten class
what they're supposed to do is they're
supposed to write a little letter
saying hey i'm so and so and i live at
this place
and you know this is where i'm from and
blah blah
and they're supposed to attach these
letters to balloons
let the balloons go and then hope that
whoever finds the balloon writes back to
them and becomes their pen pal
the teacher of the kindergarten class so
this would be like a cute sort of
project for the kids to do to show
you know how far the balloons would go
and then like you'd come back and if you
get a letter back from somebody that
you know wrote back to you because
they'd put in a letter from the school
too saying you know this you know this
is a project that we're doing with these
little kids and
we would really appreciate it if you
wrote back to them and blah blah
you know with a picture of where you
live and and crap like that
you know so everything everybody that
got like a letter or picture or whatever
they would put on this big map in the
classroom so the narrator is very
excited about this and works very hard
on doing the letter
and talks about what you know what his
interests are and all this other stuff
says where he lives
and please write back to me and he draws
like a little picture of like a um
like a little stick figure uh with
holding the balloon on it
so he sends the balloon away now a long
time goes by like the school year kind
of goes by and he doesn't get anything
and he's really like disappointed like a
lot of the other kids get letters
you know and some of them get letters
like back and forth for quite a while
but then you know obviously people would
stop writing to them because you know
who the hell wants to write to a
six-year-old kid for all that long
you know if you're an adult or whoever
found the balloon and some people don't
get anything because obviously their
balloons got lost or the people didn't
bother writing back or whatever
but so he's really bummed out that he
doesn't get anything but then like i
think it's like six months later or
something like that
like the teacher comes up to him and
says um i think this is for you
like even though it didn't have his name
on it it did have kind of a mirror of
the picture that he had drawn
like of the um of the stick figure with
the balloon so he's like okay well this
is for you
so he opens it only there's no letter in
there and there's no return address and
there's nothing like that all that's in
there
is this really really blurry polaroid
that doesn't really seem to have any
significance or anything like that
whatsoever
see this kind of thing creeps me out
like just because there's no context
around it
so it's like when i was i mean i really
liked the first part of the thing too
like with the kid in the woods and
everything but when it got to this like
getting the
polaroid back and i was like oh i'm
invested in this now this is like some
creepy [ __ ]
then it turns out that as the school
year goes on he keeps getting
these random ass polaroid pictures
that are all blurry and they don't seem
to be anything they don't seem to be
you know they're just like pictures of
random [ __ ] like there's like a picture
of like a park or here's a picture of
like part of a roof or something like
that
for whatever even though he's bummed out
and he's like i don't know who the [ __ ]
is sending these
you know he kind of keeps him because
he's like i don't know maybe i don't he
just keeps him for whatever reason
because he just thinks it's neat that
he's getting them back even though he
has no idea what they mean but then
okay so what ended up happening is that
uh
he also he had also sent with the letter
that he sent with the balloon
he had also sent a dollar in the
envelope like for the people to buy
postage and he had written because he
was six
and he wrote on the dollar for stamps
like in a marker
so a while later like over the summer or
whatever him and his
best friend josh are having like they
have a snow cone stand or whatever
and whoever like somebody buys a snow
cone
and that dollar bill comes back to him
and he gets really excited
about this he's like wow somebody bought
stamps and then
you know and then it went through like
who knows how many doll how many hands
this dollar went through before it came
back to me he thought that was really
neat
so him getting the dollar back reminds
him to go back and look at all the weird
polaroids that he got and he got he
ended up getting like 50 of them which
was like more than anybody
and he's six so he doesn't think he
thinks it's weird but he doesn't think
anything's sinister
but then he goes back and looks at all
the polaroids and he realizes
that he is in every single one of them
like even from like far away and [ __ ]
like that so obviously
someone is stalking this child
and at that point it was oh i just got
goosebumps just selling talking about
it and it's like so when i was like read
the book i was like oh
no that's like really really creepy and
then so
so like i said as it goes on there's
like other vignettes about
you know you finding out other aspects
of what was going on
and the story just gets bigger and
bigger you really like i said you really
don't find out exactly
where how all the pieces fit together
until the end because he's talking about
like the last uh part of it which is
called friends
he's talking in the present day to his
mother
and she's filling in a bunch of blanks
about stuff that he didn't know
that happened at the time you know so it
kind of like casts light on this really
big sinister
kind of [ __ ] that was going on like this
stalking situation like a pedophile
essentially he was stalking him all this
time
in like really really super creepy ways
and he didn't really have
because he was a kid he didn't really
have any idea of the magnitude of it
until he was remembering back and
talking to his mother in the present day
and she was filling gaps in and then it
all came like horribly horribly clear
like what
was going on all of this time as i said
it's not uh
it's not a linear story it's not done
like a narrative
you know three act structure type of
thing but
i don't know i just think the way that
it was done was like really really
effective even though it's not
you know even though it jumps around in
time even though you know sometimes i
don't want to say like it repeats itself
it doesn't really because
even if it kind of repeats a little bit
of the same time period
it's casting a light on different
aspects of something that was happening
like
there's characters that you know do and
say things
that don't make any sense in one
particular memory but then like an
earlier or later memory you'll be like
oh that's right
this happened then and you have to kind
of so it's one you really kind of have
to pay attention to because it jumps
back and forth
and a lot of details link to other
details
that you know were either like earlier
or later in the story you know what i'm
saying so it's almost kind of like it's
structured like a person's memory
memories of childhood are really
structured
and as i said i think the reason it
works so well
is because of it's it's not necessarily
ambiguous because when you read it like
you know you'll know what happened
like by the end you'll be like oh okay
that's what happened and then everything
will fit together
but while you're reading it you're never
really entirely sure
like you kind of know what's you know
[ __ ] sinister before he does because
like i said he was a kid and he didn't
really understand what was going on and
there was a lot of things
that he didn't know uh because the
adults were keeping it from him because
he was little
so you you will know more things than he
knows
but you still don't know entirely what's
going on one criticism i saw
of this which i don't share but one
criticism i saw
said well they didn't like that you
didn't really get a lot of
characterization
and you never got an explanation or
you know a reason or anything like why
this pen pal
you know this stalker if you want to
call him that why he was doing it but to
me
that made it scarier because i was just
like
he was just like a random dude and
that's kind of another theme of the book
too
is that random ass [ __ ] happens you know
what i mean this kid sends this balloon
up in the air and anybody could have got
it but the person that got it was the
worst person imaginable
that could have received it and decided
that they were going to completely
obsess over this kid for years and years
and the fact that you never find out who
he was you never found
find out what his name was you never
find out anything like that
but like i said to me that made it
scarier because it's like it could be
anybody
you know what i mean and to me that like
creeped me out even more
some people also kind of criticized
though maybe the stuff you know some of
the things that happened were like too
unbelievable or it was too contrived or
anything
i didn't really find that either like i
said you know if you like
a lot of the stories that are on no
sleep it's this is kind of like that but
in a much more
expanded book form so i don't imagine if
you like that style i don't imagine that
you wouldn't
like this because to me this had
everything
that i really like about those type of
stories
where they're ambiguous enough to
keep you interested and keep your
imagination working so you can
kind of project yourself into the story
as well which i think is really good i
really liked
all the stuff when he was like
remembering stuff from his childhood
even when they were doing regular [ __ ]
like you know building up their
building their snow cone stand and he
was like talking about that
i was like i don't know that's maybe
some people thought that that was like
detail that it'd be in there
but to me that just like heightened that
because i had a snow cone machine like
that and it's like i remember
you know so so you can cast your own
childhood back into it
yourself back into that you know into
that space and it's very like
universalized in a way so i really
thought that was really really well done
and like i said i'm still thinking about
this book i'm still thinking about and
i'm looking forward to
actually rereading it because i think
there was a lot of links that maybe i
didn't pick up on
i think i picked up on most of the stuff
like i got the gist of the big story and
everything
but i think there was a lot more things
that that may be linked up that i didn't
catch the first time around so i'll
definitely be uh rereading this again
and like i said
this is actually an expanded version as
far as i know you can
still read all the uh the vignettes
for free because they were on reddit but
the
novelization of it is longer and there's
like stuff added to it
but there's also like an audio podcast
of the original vignette so you can
listen to that as well which i've heard
is actually really good
but um which i'll probably do at some
point although
i really liked uh the way this novel was
laid out but but i can see how
some people might think it might work
better as like connected vignettes
but you know that's kind of what the
novel is but it has more of a
little bit more of a structure to it i
don't know but like i said it's
it's weird to me how divisive the
reviews
of this are because i genuinely loved
this book i just got
so immersed in it it creeped me out so
much
each of the vignettes is cool because
it's almost kind of like self-contained
which makes sense because that's how
they were written originally it wasn't
originally supposed to be a novel length
thing but so each one of them kind of
ends
not in a cliffhanger necessarily but in
a kind of revelation
you know what i mean so you can totally
read each vignette
as its own story and it's still creepy
but
the way that they all fit together just
makes it really really satisfying
i will say that there's one uh there's
one vignette called
boxes which is about his kitty
and even though it doesn't like
say anything explicit about what happens
to boxes because boxes is the name of
the cat that one i think made me the
most
apprehensive because because you guys
though i love cats
and so anytime i read a horror novel and
there's a cat like is introduced i'm
like oh no
like i start getting that feeling of
dread in the pit of my stomach because i
know something bad's gonna happen to the
cat
so even though something bad does happen
to the cat it's not
explicitly detailed so like i said if
you're like me
just know that that's in there because i
think that was the section that bothered
me the most
you know what i mean you guys know how
it's like you know i love kitties that's
all i could say
all right so anyway i would highly
highly recommend this like i said this
is
easily one of my favorite books that i
read uh during this uh
this show that i've been doing it's just
i really really enjoyed it i read it
very very quickly because i just didn't
want to put it down i don't know there's
just really this vibe about it that i
was really into like i said it kind of
remain
it kind of made me remember my own
childhood because there was
you know there there were a lot of
similar things like you know me and my
brother we used to play in the woods
like i said we had a snow cone machine
just like that we had the walkie-talkies
we you know
going and exploring and all this other
kind of stuff so it really kind of like
brought
that all back and the fact that there's
all this sinister [ __ ] like just lurking
around the edges
just made it so much i don't know it
just really really hit a sweet spot for
me i guess
which you know it's not gonna be for
everybody i suppose but like i said i
don't
i don't get some of the one star reviews
that were on goodreads i'm just i don't
get it because i thought it was amazing
but you know everybody's gonna have a
different opinion
so you know how that goes but yeah i
personally i loved it and i would really
recommend it if you like that kind of
thing especially if you like like i said
creepypastas or that kind of thing
but yeah it's called pen pal by dathan
auerbach
from 2012 and that will do it for my
tomes of tarot show and i'll see you
guys on the next one
bye